ヤンキーヤンキー完全ヤンキーだわ
気を付けてね
霊感のある後輩でございます
はじめ：こんばんは
急に動かなくなってしまいました
拍手するとこじゃねぇ
はじめ：ほんと危なかったんでしょ？
後輩：危なかったですよ本当に、国道で普通にブンッって
やばっ
後輩：全くないっす全然、新しいんで
おむつ塚でございます
おむつ塚と呼ばれるちょっと変わった名前の心霊スポットです
この”おむつ”は紙おむつのことではなく
”おむつさん”という女性の名前が由来になっています
後輩：土地を納めてる偉い人じゃないですか？
結婚する前にヒカキンさんのとこに挨拶行かなきゃいけない（笑）
嫁入りが決まったおむつもヒカキンさんに挨拶に行ったのだが
その美貌にヒカキンさんは目を奪われて強引に
服を脱がしてしまいました
ヒカキンさーーん
ヒカキンさん悪い人みたいになちゃったw
イメージですからね
当時の村をYouTuberで現したヒカキンさんみたいな感じ
で、おむつは必至にそのヒカキンさんを振りほどき
なんとか逃げました
でも諦めることができなかったヒカキンさんは
おむつを自分の物にしようと牢屋に閉じ込めてしまいました
で、ヒカキンさんは幾度となくおむつに関係を迫ったが
拒否されるばかり
エグイな、これだけ聞くと
その事実を知ったおむつの母親はお墓を作った
それから数日後
庄屋は原因不明の死を遂げたと
いうお話で
その時近くに住んでた人の話によると
庄屋さんがね少し前から気が狂って奇声をあげたり暴れてたらしくて
死ぬ前にはですね家族や家来全員を刀で切り殺してたらしいです
これがね、おむつの祟りだと恐れ悲しむ人々は生き埋めになった場所を
塚にして、ちゃんと何か作って供養したと
ありがとうございやす
今から行くのはそのおむつさんの塚でございます
結構高めなんですよ
割と高レベルな場所なんで
場所が怖いんですけども
今回はその”おむつ塚”まで行ってみようと思います
じゃあ早速向かいますか
( ^)o(^ )
♪～♪
後輩：事故車両だ
はじめ：うわ、ほんとじゃんガチじゃん
後輩：うわーがっつりイっちゃってるなー
女の子だったら”渚”で
男だったら”バトルソーサラー龍之介”
（ナビ）：目的地周辺です
もう着きますよ
降りてみないとわかんないよね
後輩：急にパッって来られても
はじめ：ね
後輩：心の準備が
なんか今声がすごい怖かった
はいというわけでちょっと一回止めて
歩いてその塚を探して行こうと思います
じゃ行きますか
後輩：またこれだ
後輩：うわビックリした、らいうぅ
後輩：どっちが喋った？
後輩：はじめさん...
はじめ：死ぬかと思った今
ここを右に曲がります
この道だよ？
後輩：そうっすね..もう...ありえないっすよ
聞こえるよね
怖いんだけどホントに
後輩：到着？
はじめ：到着しました
後輩：わっ一気に変わった
一気に雰囲気が、がらっと変わりました
ここのどこかに塚があるというわけで
探しに行きましょう
寒気がすごいんだけどもう
怖くて逃げるしゃちょー（大嘘）